الذي اعلن فيه القائد العام لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلومه عبدي رفضه
المقترحه الروسي القائم على تسليم النظام
المناطق الحدوديه مع تركيا في الشمال
السوري لتجنيب المنطقه عمليه عسكريه تركيه
اضاف ان قواته لم تستلم هذه المناطق
لتسلمها انما حررتها من تنظيم الدوله وفق
تصريحاته ونقلت وسائل اعلام كرديه عن عبدي
قوله انه لا يمكن تفكيك قواته في حاله
توصل الى اي تسويه سياسيه بشان الاوضاع في
سوريا معتبرا ان هذه القوه تستطيع ان تكون
جزءا من المنظومه الدفاعيه السوريه
مستقبلا
الان نرحب من اسطنبول بمراسله الجزيره عمر
الحاج ومن اعزاز في ريف حلب بمراسل
الجزيره محمد الجزائري مرحبا بكما ونبدا
ميدانيا اذا معك محمد الجزائري لتطلعنا
على المناطق التي تم استهدافها من الجيش
التركي
وعده مواقع خرافي مناطق في المنطقه
الحدوديه شمال منطقه همم محافظه محافظه
الحسكه بالاضافه الى مواقع اخرى شمال عين
العرب واا منبج هذه الاستهدافات في
الحقيقه تراجعت وترتها عن ايام السابقه
وخصوصا مع تواجد همم المفاوضات مع قوات
سوريا
الديمقراطيه ان كان من الجانب الروسي او
من الجانب الامريكيه وكما ذكرت انها قائد
ما يعرف قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه رفضت هذه
القوات المقترح الروسي في حين يرى هناك
همم خبراء عسكريون ان المعركه العسكريه
البريه التركيه في المنطقه باتت وشيكا
وخصوصا مع تعندد ما تعرف القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه للتفاوض والقبول بالشروط التي
قد ت همم توقف هذه العمليه العسكريه في
المنطقه ويرى الخبراء ان هناك تعقيدات في
المنطقه هناك تعقيد في المنطقه ومع تواجد
قوات النظام التي توافدت الى مناطق ما
تعرف القوى السيول سوريا الديمقراطيه ان
كان في عين العرب ومن بجوه الرفعت
وتمركزها في عده نقاط مهمه واستراتيجيه
واهمها في محيط مدينه في مطار من العسكري
الذي يقع في ناحيه تل رفعت هذا التمركز
ايضا يتواجد هناك عربات روسيه تتواجد الى
المنطقه وتخرج من المنطقه بشكل متكرر همم
في الحقيقه اما ميدانيا فالجيش الوطني
تابع للمعارضه رفع جاهزيته بشكل كامل وبدا
نشر وتعزيز مواقع على خطوط القتال مع ما
تعرف بالقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في حال
بدا اي عمليه عسكريه للمشاركه فيها هذه
العمليه العسكريه البريه في حال بدات في
اي لحظه
القناه ايضا محمد الجزائري
وننتقل الى عمر اذا عمر انت في تركيا في
وقت المعارضه والقلق الامريكي من استمرار
هذه العمليه على اشده ولكن يبدو ان تركيا
ماضيه في عزمها على التصعيد
واعطاء المهله هل هناك اي ردود فعل جديده
فيما يتعلق بالموقف التركي الرسمي
لابد اننا ان نشير الى اننا في ضوء هذه
التصريحات التركيه همم للجزيره يوم امس
تستطيع ان نقرا الكثير من الدلالات في هذه
المفاوضات التي يبدو انها ماسونيه او
مكوكيه بين كل من الجانبين الروسي والتركي
على حيدن والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وانقره من جهه اخرى لكن هذه الدلالات على
راسها ان هناك عنادا تركيا على ما يبدو
على تحقيق كل هذه المطالب بل انا نرى ان
هناك سقفا مرتفعا للمطالب التركيه سواء من
الجانبين الامريكي والروسي عندما تتحدث
تركيا بالاضافه الى الاتحاد من كامل
الشريط الحدود وايضا تخلي عن مدينتي عين
العرب ومنبجره لها اهميه استراتيجيه
ورمزيه لهذه الوحدات تتحدث ايضا عن رفع
ايده وسيطرته هذه الوحدات عن خزان سوريا
النفطي عن تركيا تقول في محادثاتها انها
تشترط ان ترفع هذه الوحدات يدها عن
الموارد النفطيه ويتحدث عن ابار دير الزور
السته وطني الى حقول الشدادي والميلان
والقامشلي وهي المورد المالي الكبير لهذه
الوحدات والتي ربما واحد من اهم اسباب
البقاء لها بالاضافه لي ما تقول تركيا
الدعم المستمر الامريكي بالسلاح بالغطاء
الجوي تركي ايضا تتحدث عن ربما هنا ملامح
جديده للمهله نتحدث عن اكثر من شهر ربما
بشرط ان تفضل مفاوضات او تفضي هذه
المباحثات الى الانسحاب الى تطبيق هذه همم
المطالب التركيه والا تركيا مجبره كما
تقول انها ستعود مره اخرى لهذه العمليه
العسكريه ايضا تركيا تتحدث هنا همم ربما
في رساله للجانب التركي ان الجانب الروسي
وعددها بالسماح باستخدام الغطاء الجوي او
رفع الحظر عن استخدام الطيران اثناء
العمليه العسكريه ربما هذا المطلب همم
تركي مهم همم تنسيق هناك ايضا على تنازلات
في الملف الاوكراني ولكن هذا شان الملف
السور الذي تعاقد همم ينتظر هذه التصريحات
وان هناك ارتباطات اخرى وان جانب الروسي
ربما يضغط على الجانب التركي في هذه
المساله كمان تركيا لها دور مهم في في
العمليه الاوكرانيه ولكن ما نستطيع القول
الان ان تركيا ماضيه في هذه تريد انها
تنافذ هذه العمليه في حال رفضت هذه
القرارات او في حاله رفضت هذه الطلبات ما
نزلنا نتحدث عن عين العرب اضافه الى من
الدول التي كما ذكرت لها اهميه استراتيجيه
ورمزيه لهذه الوحدات ولا نتحدث ايضا عن
مهله في ربما في شهر وفي شهر اكثر حتى
تنفذ هذه المطالب شكرا
الجزائري الريف حلب